It’s also important even before the situation at the
Zapariya nuclear power plant for the Race, the whole
view of my boots with a view Total now the Spire
on the bespek will completely lie down the view of the
global respect where we swim in at the
station Russia half reading
is informative you Swift budget For what
scenarios are there terrorists and suite
ready
radiation for everyone for  all
radioactive incidents today Reno 16
months I to the Russian viscos completely
controls the territory of TASS rocks
from different powers of the retinues and the authorities did not
scout
to know exactly what
they are in what you at a time the type of our intelligence
we give me information about the test that in Doha
Kilkukh power units in the Zapariya
nuclear  station Russian Viskov
placed and objects similar skills can be
concluded so that with them Tuvat strike at the station they
can have a smaller scenario
for Budek payout Sweet Badji and
soaked batchaty still united
for steaming the nuclear plant e most
Russia and no one engineer the
situation is quite tense
because the threat of sabotage is really great
on the part of the Kiev regime,
which can have
catastrophic consequences, has
repeatedly demonstrated its
readiness for nothing, very recently we have
seen explosions with
horrific consequences, so of course,
take all measures to
counteract this. As a
result of
this important visit, the
Russian Chairman was
provided with quite a lot of
information; there were statements for the press; the
essence  the negotiations
were clearly set out in the
documents adopted following the application, so there is
a lot of information and everything else
is